can elsa really create life is there a
walt disney company in arendelle and is
there any order in the world of frozen
here are some big questions that we're
still left with from the frozen movies
the very first sequence in frozen shows
a group of ice harvesters while
harvesting ice naturally they sing as
they do harmonizing about how though
they must chop away at the ice they mine
everyone must beware the frozen heart
hinting at a key plot point later on in
the film the men chip away at large
formations of ice and carry stacks of it
away in a sled pulled by a reindeer
alongside the team is a young boy with a
baby reindeer and miniature sleigh of
his own happy to do his part the boy
affectionately calls the reindeer sven
implying they have an established
relationship as pet owner and pet we
later come to know the young boy as
kristoff but we never discover just how
he and sven became a duo it could make
for an adorable origin story sven sticks
by kristoff's side through adulthood a
better friend to him than any other
person it would be interesting to learn
the origins of their bond
the troll's parental relationship to
kristoff is always presented as friendly
but the dynamic between them has some
red flags with minimal context at the
beginning of frozen if the audience is
to assume anything it would be that
young kristoff might be the son of one
of the ice harvesters that he loyally
accompanies to work at the very least he
knows these guys while no adults say
anything directly to kristoff during the
ice harvesting scene or vice versa he's
with them the entire time and is clearly
connected to this pack in some way
kristoff and sven then stumble upon a
troll colony at which point one of the
trolls hugs them and proclaims
cuties
i'm gonna keep you
um
what kristoff later shares that he was
raised by the trolls and considers them
his family but that doesn't justify why
the trolls abducted a human child and
reindeer to keep as their own it would
be different if kristoff was shown as a
distressed wanderer or if viewers
definitively knew he doesn't have
another family but since he was with the
ice harvesters earlier surely one of
them is related to him or knows him
somehow somewhere out there could there
be a family worried about the child they
lost in the woods and never found
regardless kristoff's upbringing doesn't
seem to bother him and if he has any
memories of his life before the trolls
he never talks about it on screen when
playtime goes wrong and young elsa
accidentally strikes anna with her icy
powers the royal family seeks healing
and answers from the trolls grand pobby
leader of the trolls heals anna but
decides to remove any memories she has
of elsa's magic he also gives strict
dramatic instructions to elsa to control
her powers warning her fear
will be your enemy
no
to prevent harm that may happen in the
future from elsa's unpredictable powers
her parents then reduce their staff and
limit elsa's interactions with others
going forward poor elsa she has
abilities she doesn't understand and
rather than patiently offering guidance
and helping her find a solution every
authority figure around elsa instead
frightens her with worst case scenarios
and extreme overreactions even worse she
has to hide who she is from her sister
her closest friend grand bobby doesn't
handle that conversation the way he
should and elsa's parents likewise make
the situation worse despite their
intentions as the audience later
witnesses elsa is fated to deal with the
implications of this traumatizing moment
of parenting for the rest of her life
it was a cameo that was endlessly freeze
framed blink and you'll miss it but
during the song for the first time in
forever sharp-eyed viewers can spot
disney royalty among the crowd as the
gates of arendelle open and anna
excitedly bounces through the sea of
people arriving to celebrate elsa's
coronation day among the guests are none
other than rapunzel and flynn rider from
2010's tangle yes the fitz herberts
themselves are right here in arendelle
but why are they here and how do they
know elsa to answer that fans may need
to take a deep dive into disney
conspiracy theories in 2014 frozen
filmmakers participated in an ask me
anything session on reddit upon being
asked where anna and elsa's parents were
traveling to when their ship crashed
director jennifer lee said they were
going to a wedding and suggested that
the parents survived and wound up on the
shores of africa giving birth to tarzan
a tumblr user took the ball and ran with
it suggesting the wedding in question
was rapunzel and flynn's which would add
validity to the couple's cameo and
frozen going further down the rabbit
hole it was suggested that the crashed
ship was the vessel explored by ariel
and flounder in the little mermaid the
events of frozen 2 render this theory
null and void of course but it's still
fun to imagine sometimes it seems a
hidden character is nothing more than
just that viewers first meet wandering
oaken when anna stumbles upon his
trading post in frozen he sells anything
a traveler might need for their journey
as well as offering a relaxing sauna
session which his family is enjoying at
the time of ana's visit as luck would
have it oaken is hosting a big summer
blowout with everything marked down it's
all in the name but wandering oaken does
indeed do his share of venturing out and
about over the course of the frozen
series despite seemingly having
permanent residence in a cabin in the
woods quite the entrepreneur in the 2015
short film frozen fever ochen operates a
mobile pharmacy while in 2019's frozen 2
he's a mobile manicurist while the
audience might not know oaken's full
backstory he's a man of many talents and
seems to be in the right place at the
right time whenever these characters
need something he sells
prince hans hails from the southern
isles wesselton to be exact which is as
its duke so frequently insists
pronounced wesselton not
weaseltown your majesty
the duke of weaseltown wesselton
duke of wesleton
when hans arrives in erindale it doesn't
take long for princess anna to become
smitten with him after only one evening
together the two decide to get married
it's all a ruse however after elsa flees
following an icy incident hans
ultimately reveals his plan to take over
the throne of arendelle no matter the
cost even if it means killing anna and
elsa once things get sorted out airdl
royal staff send hans and the duke back
to wesselton where they're hopeful that
hans's 12 older brothers will dutifully
punish them in frozen fever fans get a
small glimpse at what hans is up to in
wesleton scooping manure it seems his
brothers put him in his place after all
though it would be great to see what
went down when hans first returned how
did his family take it when they learned
han's attempted homicide and where's the
duke han's and anything to do with
wesselton is absent and frozen too as
the story moves on to other narratives
and characters
for elsa to be cursed with the power of
ice and snow there are certainly a lot
of extra capabilities she seems to
possess that have nothing to do with
temperature perhaps the most ridiculous
is that she can
create life yep elsa can apparently
insert life into snow from olaf the
huggable snowman to marshmallow the
terrifying snow monster granted frozen 2
adds a little more credibility to elsa's
seemingly bizarre skill set it turns out
that she's actually the fifth spirit
along with earth air fire and water that
make up the elements of nature elsa's
powers derive from her mother selflessly
saving her father when the couple was
young nature rewarded elsa's mom's
heroism with elsa's powers this might
not add clarity to any common thread
among elsa's audibilities but it at
least gives some reasoning behind why
they're more than just ice
charades is the activity of choice
during family game night in frozen two
when it's olaf's turn and he has to mime
the word mouse he promptly puts two of
his circle-shaped coals on either side
of his head [ __ ] out his heel puts one
of his arms out and puts on a huge smile
this is an unmistakable charade of
mickey mouse kristoff correctly guesses
the word from olaf's clues olaf could
have simply acted like an actual mouse
maybe pretending to have whiskers or
mimicking the nimble way mousey's cheese
the fact that he instead chooses to
imitate mickey implies a few things
about arendelle that makes this simple
wink to disney history complicated if
kristoff and olaf know who mickey mouse
is does that mean there's a walt disney
company in the fictional world of frozen
but if the movies take place before the
dawn of electricity that means there's
no such thing as cartoons or movies yet
how is mickey a recognizable figure to
them our tales of this plucky mouse
passed on as oral stories this logic
could also be applied to olaf presents a
series of shorts in which olaf acts out
favorite disney animated movies like the
little mermaid and moana best not to
overthink it too much perhaps
the geography of arendelle and its
surrounding village and forest are never
quite explained in full detail this
leads to some questions about where the
trolls lived during the events of frozen
and if they live somewhere different
during frozen two the journey to visit
the trolls is shown to be an extensive
voyage in frozen but in frozen 2 the
trolls arrive rather quickly when the
elements begin to invoke harm upon
arendelle this implies that even if the
trolls still live in their colony in the
mountains it's considered within the
confines of arendelle's kingdom since
they experienced the elements the same
as the rest of the village their
swiftness and near comical abruptness
arriving on scene to conveniently
explain everything that's happening
implies that they either moved closer to
the kingdom proper or they're just
really fast travelers who roll around
all over the place
olaf came to life through elsa's magic
and in frozen 2 viewers learned that his
existence relies on elsa's survival as
she becomes weak and eventually freezes
olaf for lack of a better word dies his
snowman form disintegrates into
snowflakes and rests itself in a pile
all's well that ends well however as
elsa is revived and is able to use that
same pile of snow to bring olaf back to
life this connection solidifies that
there's clearly strong magic between
elsa and olaf though this is the first
time that elsa's health appears to have
affected that of olaf for example when
elsa was sick in frozen fever olaf
seemed fine is it only life-and-death
situations that prompt this connection
between the two of them or are there
other circumstances that lead to
something happening to olaf as a result
of what elsa is experiencing also can
the bond ever go in the reverse
direction where something happening to
olaf would affect elsa oh look at that
i've been impaled
living rock formations represent the
earth element of the five spirits in
frozen two they're huge and destructive
and ana realizes they're her only hope
to set things right she discovers that
the dam at the river thought to be a
symbol of unity was built with malicious
intent in order to save everyone the dam
must be broken but how do you destroy a
sturdy generations old structure some
big scary rock monsters might do the
trick hana lures them toward the dam by
acting as bait and correctly guesses
that the creatures will throw rocks in
her she utilizes some impeccable
coordination skills running at full
sprint while dodging boulders being
tossed at her from behind sometimes she
just barely dodges the rocks by inches
it's an impressive feat maybe it's that
soon to be queen power or a rock radar
akin to spidey sense but anna comes out
on the other side without a scratch
in frozen 2 we learned that elsa is a
fifth spirit of nature along with earth
air fire and water elsa first begins her
journey to discovering who she really is
by following a melodic call she hears in
the distance eventually she finds out
that the call is being sung by none
other than her deceased mother beckoning
her to learn her true purpose so how
does the afterlife work within the
frozen universe elsa's mother exists
somewhere despite having died in her
physical form on earth and is visible to
elsa somewhat like a projection on the
walls of an icy cavern before anna and
elsa's parents died and frozen it was
clear that they didn't understand elsa's
powers in the slightest in frozen 2
elsa's mom not only understands elsa's
powers but is the authority on how she
can step into what she was meant to do
all along what happened in between that
led to the shift in perspective and
awareness how did elsa's mother in death
learn the truth and how did she know how
to contact elsa
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie theories are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one